welcome calculator fanciers to another
numberphile calculator unboxing I'm Matt
Parker and today I'm going to be looking
at this this is a real classic of the
genre this is the casio FX series this
is an FX 85 GT plus and it's not only on
the packet it is written right across
the top of the calculator I mean but I'm
getting ahead of myself we're not inside
the packet yet let's just have a look at
what's promised on the back there's a
full breakdown of the calculator tells
you where all the buttons are
predominantly as you can see on the
front of the calculator and then it
mentions several the functions most of
which you don't actually get in the
counter so this is basically saying that
there are other calculators which are
better than this one it's a unusual
thing to say on a product that you're
not buying the best one but if you look
at the top here this is not the UK's
number one scientific calculator it's
the UK's number one scientific
calculator brand not this specific one
but that mean it can do a lot you can
see on here it's got 260 functions that
is a big number of functions it can do
prime factorizations it's got
reoccurring decimals very exciting and
it can verify your expression so if you
look particularly excited or very
surprised at a calculation it could
verify that expression when you can see
here it comes with a three-year
guarantee it's guaranteed that the
fundamental laws of mathematics will not
change within the first three years of
purchasing this calculator after that
all bets are off one may become a prime
number dividing by 0 may be allowed we
just don't know
ok so let's pop this open and see what
actually happens so again we'll get our
handy scalpel as you can see I'm making
one incision on the top corner very very
carefully slicing towards myself and so
I keep a good view of the blade will now
cut down the long alongside I like that
being careful to not cut through any of
the instruction or other materials
inside and they will come around this
last corner one final dangerous cut we
are through most of the packet and none
of my fingers alright this now hinges
open there we go okay there's the
calculator all the instructions are
protected here in case you get so
excited opening it there's a risk of
fluids being splashed on the
instructions they come a little packet
there if we put our wow there's a proper
stapled booklet here how to initialize
the calculator so there's a lot of text
there for how to press the on button
handling precautions because if you
don't have a firm grip it might slip out
on a fast calculation corner how to read
the display if you've not yet learnt to
read in fact even if you can't read
possibly buying a calculator is getting
a bit ahead of yourself I recommend
learning to read before learning how to
use a calculator and there's a lot here
and I could spend the entire video
reading this which believe me is
tempting but we will leave that for
later on and then now these are all the
bits that they forgot to put in the
booklet when they first wrote it and so
they had to put them on an extra piece
of paper and then they forgot to put
some bits into this piece of paper which
is why there's another piece of paper in
fact there are several I mean frankly
whoever's in charge of coming up with
the instructions should be fired ok so
let's get rid of all that and have a
look at the calculator itself oh look at
it ok so it comes with a taped on back
phony I had a sharp implement to remove
that okay so will cut through the back
there will cut through the tape there
and this should now slide off very nice
and then this little bit of plastic here
okay I have no idea what that if anyone
has any idea what this is for please do
let me know I can only assume it's
something vitally important so I'm going
to very very carefully fold it up and
put it back in the packet for when I
later realize what I'm in to use that
for okay the actual calculator here we
go there's a variety of powers of X
there's two ways to power it if you look
very very closely at the panel you can
see that there are four different panels
this that is the first inaccurate
mistake on the calculator if we switch
it on oh look at that the whole display
leaps in it starts off in degrees again
a bit of a risk there and we can fit one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen seventeen eight are the
digital just there scrolling off the
other side this this can fit a lot of
digits and we're only using the top
rrrow I mean there's a lot of potential
here I'm if it wasn't for the fact that
now mobile phones have shown you how
good screens can be you'd be impressed I
mean if this was the mid-90s that would
be a fantastic screen on an electronic
device let's see how the accuracy goes
so one way to test the accuracy is we'll
try one divided by nine which should
give us a ninth oh it's actually just
written a ninth and if we try
multiplying that by nine it should of
course give us one back that's very good
it's also very good for converting
thirds so let's say you want to know the
square root of 17 you simply type square
root of 17 you hit equals and it tells
you that it's the square root of 17 very
insightful there Casio the square root
of 17 is exactly equal to the square
root of 17 marvels now through all of
this you might be wondering look this is
a good calculator but it's a bit mutual
how can i express my feminine side Casio
has got you covered with the pink look
at that they're pink Casio exactly the
same FX the 85 GT only this time it's
the plus pink this one here was just the
Plus this is plus nothing this one here
is plus pink if we crack that one open
and if I'm not careful it's going to be
plus blood going right on the side okay
once we are in here okay we can see that
it is identical there's all the same
instructions the front of it is the same
it's got that same very important bit of
plastic if I cut through the identical
pieces of tape there we now have the
same exactly the same calculator that
does all exactly the same things except
it is surrounded by a pink face at last
a calculator caters to people who like
the color pink now know what some of you
are thinking wait a minute did this this
is a little bit sexist how on earth
could you have a pink calculator and no
other colors well that's fine anyone who
thinks that's too sex as they do of
course have a blue calculator there you
are this is this
entire Casio range if you a male/female
on non-identifying then you have or you
wish to be neutral if you think that
gender doesn't come into mathematics
then of course you can use the classic
there there are otherwise absolutely
identical they all fit in the hand the
same way final scores for the casio FX 8
3g t plus in both the neutral blue and
pink models overall I give the displays
9.5 they are very good functionality
eighth accuracy 10 you cannot fault the
precision economics and 9 fits nicely in
the hand cred 9 although it does depend
heavily what model and what gender
you're pairing up and finally for
durability
for durability we'll run it over and
it's still got I mean obviously the
gendered ones haven't fared so well but
the every person calculator still still
ticking along school I have to give that
a 10 that brings us to a grand total of
55 point 5 which is an amazing average
score of nine point two five I feel like
I mean the main feature of this is the
fact that you can attach it to your
wrist you can you can strap it on and
that is very important very few
calculators can do that in fact I've got
another for comparison casio calculator
here and if you try and balance that on
you it's incredibly difficult to do
calculations on your wrist